okay so the devil all the time is pretty
much
god works in mysterious ways the movie
and it has a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video we'll be breaking
down the symbolism of the piece
the true meaning behind it and also its
ending there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to check
out the movie yet then i highly
recommend that you check out now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up as it massively
helps us out
as always this is the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition
now let's get into the devil all the
time
okay so the title of the film very much
ties into the religious aspects that we
see lights throughout the piece
set primarily on the bible belt of
america in west virginia
we watch his interconnecting stories all
join together to form one overarching
narrative
that feels like a true american gothic
horror though the film feels extremely
bleak
almost relentless in its depiction of
life and death
it also ends with a glimmer of hope that
suggests there might be light at the end
of the tunnel
initially we join a world war ii veteran
named willard who's just returned from
war
after his wife is diagnosed with cancer
he becomes obsessed with prayer
and forces their son to do this almost
every day down at a makeshift vlog
which he views as his church in the book
in the movie
it's said that he prayed so much to god
that to his son it seemed like he fought
the devil all the time
however the movie goes far beyond that
throughout we joined several characters
that are constantly tempted by power
sex and their underlying desires which
they as characters either fight or give
in to
pretty much every person in the film
feels like they could give in at any
time
and because of this you guessed it
they're fighting the devil
all the time now willard is a
fascinating character
and arguably he goes on one of the most
tragic arcs in the film
after he witnesses a crucified and
skinned soldier during the war
his perception of religion in god is
altered significantly
and initially he turns his back on his
faith it's difficult to discern whether
the film actually states if god exists
or not
and one could argue that the
interconnecting stories are either
coincidence
or somewhat divine intervention on a
second watch
something that stuck out to me massively
was that willard's mother promised god
that if he returned from war
that she would make him marry another
church-goer named helen hatton
ultimately this doesn't happen and in
retrospect the majority of the tragedies
in the film
would have been avoided if she just kept
up her end of the bargain
when willard ended the diner at the
beginning of the movie a man named carl
almost takes his seat but he offers it
up to him instead
and takes another carl is then served by
a woman that would go on to become his
wife
and together the pair commit horrendous
crimes again
one could argue that had carl bean a
mere second earlier
then this would have never happened and
the simple moment of the seat switch in
him taking her photograph
have massive ramifications for the movie
the film itself is narrated by donald
ray pollock
the original author of the book and in
some ways he feels like the voice of god
aware of all that is going on in a
letter sent out along with early access
to the movie
the film's director antonio campos
stated that he wanted pollock to feel
like the voice of the creator
that knew all of the ins and outs of the
characters whether you see this as the
voice of god or not
i think it's a nice little detail that
some omnipresent person
could be overseeing everything and
letting us know how it connects
now as for willard he just can't look at
a cross without seeing that soldier
however he slowly turns back to religion
hoping to get right with his maker
before something bad happens
unfortunately it does
and as we mentioned his wife's health
begins to wane
willard convinces himself that if he
offers up enough blood
it will save her life and he kills his
dog eventually pinning it up
similar to the crucified soldier in the
hopes that it will save her
the book goes far beyond this with
willard killing more and more animals
in the hopes that he will eventually
offer up enough blood to save her life
she dies anyway and willard ends his
life the night of her funeral
a sheriff named bodeka investigates to
death after arvin raises the alarm
and this location becomes central to the
film's ending
orvin goes to live with his grandmother
and another orphan
named lenora now it's revealed that
lenora is actually the child of helen
who on the day that she was introduced
to willard was swept off her feet by a
traveling preacher named dudley
so sorry i mean roy roy and his brother
roy is a religious fanatic that even
pours live spiders on his face during
sermons to prove
his devotion and eventually after
becoming bitten he locks himself away
before coming to the conclusion that god
has a purpose for him
he believes that he can resurrect the
dead and kills his wife before screaming
to the lord to bring her back
this is similar to willard in some
respects and roy is later killed by carl
and his wife sandy
who we discover have started to pick up
hitchhikers before murdering them
now had carl not given the seat to
willard then willard would not have been
served by the woman who would go on to
become his feature wife
without her in his mind he would have
likely gone to the church
and ended up with helen roy wouldn't
have killed helen
and then as carl hadn't met sandy he
wouldn't have killed roy
it's kind of mind-blowing seeing all of
these pieces fit together
and this butterfly effect leaves lenora
and arvin growing up together without
parents
however one thing that they do have
which was passed on from them
is their faith campos stated that in his
letter one of the things that he
inherited from his parents was religion
he said that at times he feels very
conflicted over this
and during the film myself i was
wondering how
so many of the characters could still
believe in god after all they'd been
through
everyone is tested at one point and most
try to injure through it
but often if not always they turn to a
darker path
nowhere is this exemplified more than
and sheriff bodaker
played by sebastian stan he knows
something's up with his sister
but he turns a blind eye to it due to
wishing to be re-elected
he puts a temptation of power above
doing the right thing
and even kills people in the hopes of
retaining the position of sheriff
in this tiny pretty meaningless town
lenora is also tempted by a preacher
played by robert pattinson the predator
preys on young girls
using their dedication to their faith
against them he's an absolutely
despicable character
who in fact gives in to the devil in his
own desires whilst preaching to stand
against temptation
i have to say pattinson is almost
unrecognizable in the role
and with tener under his belt this and
the upcoming batman movie
the guy is on a stratospheric rise his
mannerisms feel completely alien
and he nails the contradictions of a man
who's preaching about sin
all whilst committing it nowhere is this
cemented more than in his introduction
in which he openly embarrasses lenora
and arvin's grandmother for bringing
chicken livers
he hoards them for himself saying that
he will bear the burden of this poor
person's food
when really we know it's because he
liked them the character is a complete
contradiction
lying through his teeth and i feel like
pattinson absolutely nails the gravitas
in the performance
lenora has bags put over her head by
bullies and she comes to believe that
she's ugly
thus when a man shows her some sort of
attention she of course laps it up
i think that a lot of institutions not
only the church prey on this kind of
mentality
and they seek out the vulnerable in
order to support them i grew up in quite
a religious family
and of course know that the church isn't
bad on the whole but we do know that
there exists horror stories in which
evil people
have been able to ascend lenora goes to
the preacher preston with news of her
pregnancy
and he suggests that she gets rid of it
denying any knowledge of what they did
together
the nora goes to hang herself but at the
last second she changes her mind
realizing that it's all a mistake
however it's too late and she slips
killing herself in the process this
really sparks aubanoff
who stalks preston unearthing his crimes
like his father arvin is haunted by the
idea that with religion comes his
undertone of despair
and this is cemented by him looking at
the same image of the crucifixion
that his dad did many years before he
shoots the character in his church with
the gun that hitler reportedly used in
his last moments
and clearly the character's actions have
been influenced by his father
who imbued him with the knowledge that
there must always be punishment for
wrongdoings
he says that he has to kill a preacher
because he has to
and not because he wants to which
hammers home his mentality
when arvin was a boy he was given a
black eye by bullies
and this eye for an eye mentality ends
up with a lot of characters
metaphorically
losing their sight now one thing that i
think the movie hammers home
is the idea that doing things in
someone's name just because they tell
you to
does not mean it's the right thing roy
kills his wife after believing that god
told him to do it
and on the other end of this is sandy
who participates in murders
because her husband carl tells her to
call should almost be viewed as a
personification of death
and it's only in debt that he feels a
higher power he views murder as its own
religion
and sandy though initially committed to
it begins to turn away
however she never walks away and always
finds a reason to go back
and this eventually leads to her death
also yeah
that that scene you know the one i'm
talking about with the filet sausage
that's gonna haunt my imagination for
the next 50 years or so
i'm never i'm never eating a bratwurst
again anyway
on the road they pick up arvin who's
fleeing from the law after killing
preston
they try their usual routine but after
he spots carl's gun
he realizes something is up alvin is of
course on the run as it is
and is likely in a heightened paranoid
state and thus he quickly realizes
what's going on
sandy too has a doubt and even
fantasizes about running away with arvin
however he acts too fast and kills carl
he holds his gun to sandy who holds one
back
and it's revealed that due to carl not
trusting sandy because of her actions
earlier in the film
he'd loaded it with blanks this gave her
the illusion of power
even though she didn't really have it
and in some ways it once more mirrors
roy
who believed that he had a certain
ability but it was completely one-sided
alvin discovers the photographs that
carl had kept of his victims
and he flees the pair's bodies are found
and bodeka burns the evidence of their
misdeeds
further taking the choice of hiding
things instead of doing the right thing
the exposure of these crimes could have
given a lot of families closure
but bodeka hides them and attempts to go
after alvin
he correctly guesses that alvin would
return to his father's quote-unquote
church
and the character does this to bury
their dog which is a promise that he
made as a child
he accepts that the dog needed to go
with his mother but his moment is
quickly cut
short bodeka arrives and arvind manages
to kill him
and you know what sebastian stan looks a
lot like mark hamill
yeah definitely just cast him in a luke
skywalker movie or something please
it's tragic because all of this could
have been avoided
had the sheriff arrested his sister but
instead
he gave in to his desire for power arvin
is picked up on the road
and he finally gets a chance to rest now
though we don't know what happens to the
character for defnite
he does get a moment of clarity in which
he sees his entire life
almost laid out in an instant there are
some brief cuts that actually
demonstrate what will happen to arvin
and this ending should sort of be seen
as a slide flashing before his eyes
we realize that the police discover the
truth about bulldecker
and also preston which arvin hopes will
show that he had his reasons if he ever
got caught
now whilst this is primarily seen as him
imagining what will happen
i actually think that it demonstrates
the truth of the situation
the letter from the director ends by
saying that even if you don't get a
happy ending
there's always potential for a new
beginning i think that is
very much exemplified here the person
that picks up orvin
is very similar looks wise to jesus and
he could be seen as the character's
salvation
taking him away from this pain and
misery which is cemented by the
character
looking back at the life that he's
leaving behind going forward we get
flashes of him in vietnam
as well as a child approaching an older
man at a car
i actually think that these are visions
of alvin's life after the events of the
movie
and that he will go on to be happy this
means that
even with all this bad some good will
actually come out of it
another movie was very bleak things
always have the potential to end in a
good
way life isn't really about endings
it's more about new beginnings and
seeing arvin ride off into the sunset
almost with the hopes of a better life
lets us as an audience know that
no matter how dark things seem there's
always tomorrow
that ends the movie on a high note but
what did i think of the film overall
well personally i loved it and though a
lot of criticism about the piece centers
around
how few jokes there are i can't really
see them fitting in well here at all
the tone is supposed to be a certain way
i think this would feel very jarring if
people were busting out one-liners
whilst the events play out a reactor
here is bringing their a-game
and for a lot of them it feels like some
of the meatiest rolls that they've
ever had the opportunity to to really
sink their teeth into
the film feels very no country for old
men and it's an authentic portrayal of
human emotion that i think elevated
above many
if you like gritty suspenseful thrillers
then this is a movie
that you need to check out though it's
not for everyone i still greatly enjoyed
the devil all the time
i definitely recommend that you check it
out and make up your own mind
if you haven't already obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the film
so make sure you comment below and let
me know
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
homelander which is going to be linked
at the end
we go over the main character in the
boys so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
for when it's going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september the set
will be shipped out from then so
yeah make sure you get involved now if
you want to support the channel and get
to see contents early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on the
discord server linked in the description
or a heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you being the best i'd be
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
you